bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur la lune et france alors cinq ans
après le démantèlement de la jungle de
calais comme on la surnomme peut-être de
façon mauvaise quel constat ou dresser
de la situation sur place aujourd'hui
d'abord
l'évacuation de la jungle il y a cinq
ans
était totalement nécessaire vous aviez
la dix mille personnes qui vivaient dans
des conditions absolument
dramatique et sous l'impulsion de
bernard cazeneuve
l'évacuation s'est passée de manière
extrêmement corrects et l'ensemble des
personnes évacuées ont pu accéder à un
titre de séjour simplement on n'a pas
résolu pour autant le problème de la
migration vers la grande bretagne je
rappelle que l'on a passé un certain
nombre d'accords entre la france et la
grande bretagne pour
essayer d'empêcher les flux de se
diriger de l'autre côté de la manche
mais évidemment on n'y est pas parvenu
dans votre reportage très bien fait par
ailleurs il est dit qu il y à quelques
dizaines de milles ans qui restent a
calé ce n'est pas exact en réalité vous
savez depuis le début de l'année
2021 il ya eu quinze mille tempête-t-il
de passage par la mer par la manche et
donc plus vous durcissent et les
conditions de pressage plus vous rendez
difficile
le contournement des voies légales et
donc vous avez aujourd'hui quinze mille
personnes qui ont tenté de passer la
manche
un coût
extrêmement important un coût financier
extrêmement important et avec une
dangerosité
énorme je rappelle que du côté
britannique on a expliqué à la
population de grande bretagne que le
break site allait tout résoudre mais ça
n'a rien résolu vous avez aujourd'hui
des familles qui sont séparés des deux
côtés de la manche et il est bien normal
qu'un certain nombre d'entre eux veuille
rejoindre la grande bretagne par
ailleurs vous avez un dumping social qui
est en cours aujourd'hui en grande
bretagne et qui permet un certain nombre
de gens en situation
irrégulière de travailler dans des
conditions
d'extrême précarité et donc la vraie
question qui continue à se poser c'est
de savoir
comment on doit aujourd'hui refonder la
relation avec la grande bretagne autour
de
du de la problématique de la migration
me bloquer les migrants les harceler ne
résout rien alors excusez moi donc vous
dénoncez un l'absence de solution
pérenne si je comprends bien donc est ce
que vous préconisez aujourd'hui un mois
est ce que je préconise c'est ce que
j'ai préconisé depuis près de dix ans il
faut des voies de migration légale il y
à a
calé un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont éligibles les îles et qui ont des
relations avec la grande-bretagne mais
donc il y à a calé un certain nombre de
jeunes gens dont la famille est de
l'autre côté et donc il faut des voies
de migration légale moi je ne suis pas
en train de dire qu'il faut ouvrir les
portes
de la grande bretagne elle ne le fera
pas mais je dis qu'il faut des voies de
migration légale
sans ça les bains ont fait le jeu des
passeurs on ne résout rien du tout on ne
résout rien a donné une mission à la
police qui est en permanence de déloger
les migrants ça n'a pas fait reculer le
front national ça n'empêche pas les gens
de venir ça enchérit le coût du passage
donc il y à une solution qui existe têtu
la solution du poids de migration légale
où les gens en toute sécurité pourrait
rejoindre vers la grande bretagne merci
merci beaucoup à pierre-henri d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association
france fraternité ça